on va parler de l'énergie on va parler
de l'exécutif qui a promis au TPE un
prix plafond pour l'électricité de 280
euros le mégawattheure est-ce que tous
les boulangers du Lot sont sauvés avec
cette mesure non ils en sont très loin
les boulangers les restaurateurs tous
les artisans qu'est-ce qui vous dit
votre frère il me dit que sa facture
d'électricité va être insupportable dans
les mois qui viennent malgré ça mais
bien sûr ce n'est pas une hausse
raisonnable comme le disait Emmanuel
Macron la semaine dernière c'est une
folie rendez-vous compte qu'il y a des
contrats aujourd'hui de fournitures
d'électricité qui ont été multipliées
par
ça ne suffira pas parce que la
renégociation va nous poser des
problèmes majeurs comment est-ce que on
va renégocier avec tous les fournisseurs
aujourd'hui moi je veux que nous en
venions
l'état puisque c'est l'État qui va
financer au final il y a une espèce
d'illusion dans tout cela lorsqu'on va
plafonner le prix de l'électricité
lorsqu'on va proposer les renégociations
pour que les fournisseurs baissent
puisqu'on est dans un système totalement
libéralisé le prix revendu c'est l'état
c'est le contenu au financement c'est ce
qu'a dit Bruno Le Maire vendredi c'est
une blague le cofinancement il faut
mettre des mots sur les choses c'est pas
un cofinancement
contribuable à la boulangerie la facture
et va payer l'impôt qui va avec je
souhaite que nous avons aussi sur deux
mesures radicales et j'assume cette
radicalité la première c'est de sortir
immédiatement du marché européen de
l'électricité voyez-vous je le disais il
y a quelques mois je passais pour un élu
Berlin comme les portugais mais lorsque
je le disais je passais pour illuminer
aujourd'hui il faut que nous sortions du
marché européenne l'électricité parce
que le système de calcul de l'énergie
est invraisemblable nous achetons nos
auditeurs les spectateurs comprennent
nous achetons sur le marché européen
l'électricité de l'énergie pardon qui
est de marcher boursier l'électricité 4
à 5 fois plus que le coût de production
nous avions avec le nucléaire sortons
immédiatement du marché européenne on
les accords
sortir du marché européen peut nous
permettre demain d'avoir des accords
bilatéraux comme nous l'avions avant le
marché européen de l'énergie avec les
pays voisins mais je veux que nous
allions au-delà et peut-être que nous en
parlerons avec mon collègue sénateur
communiste tout à l'heure à la
reconstruction du pays général de Gaulle
avec les communistes d'ailleurs avec
considéré que l'énergie comme
l'alimentation était des biens trop
précieux pour être soumis au marché
libéré je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'on ne doit pas pouvoir
demain échanger en bourse de
l'électricité comme on ne le fait pas
pour l'eau par exemple et je souhaite
que cette matière là ne soit pas une
matière
en eau simplement c'est un marché qui
est un marché protégé et oui pour
l'électricité je souhaite que nous
sortions du marché boursier puisque oui
c'est une manière de nationaliser mais
je n'ai pas pas de problème avec cela
vous rendez compte où nous en sommes
rentré seul dans votre politique là
quand vous faites toutes tout
l'inventaire de ce que vous venez de
nous dire sur les retraites là sur
l'électricité vous pouvez être sur la
même ligne que des communistes est-ce
que vous vous sentez bien chez LR ah oui
je me sens profondément gaulliste ce que
je vous ai dit sur votre ligne oui il en
reste beaucoup beaucoup plus que vous ne
le pensez et certains qui s'ignorent
alors
et que je tâche de réveiller ou de
révéler mais vous savez aujourd'hui sur
cinq du coup sur la base beaucoup plus
que cela et puis vous savez ce qui
compte c'est que nous reparlions aux
Français est-ce que nos concitoyens ne
se disent pas aujourd'hui que ce système
du marché européen énergie auquel
personne ne comprend rien qui consiste à
caler le prix l'électricité sur celui du
gaz alors que nous étions capables de
produire notre propre électricité et
déraisonnable vous savez ce qui me
frappe beaucoup c'est que le politique
est devenu un petit gestionnaire et que
nous avons devant nous des problèmes
gigantesques et qu'à chaque fois on
refuse d'aller à la racine il y a pas de
vision non il n'y a pas de vision
Emmanuel Macron mais pas seulement voilà
nombreuses années les autres que nous
avons mais nous avons contribué à la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ce pays ne s'est pas
effondré du jour au lendemain le marché
européen l'électricité la libéralisation
du marché européenne l'électricité qui
est-ce qu'il a fait c'est notre famille
politique sous les injonctions de
Bruxelles et de l'Europe voyez une
mesure précise depuis des années la
France résiste et à la raison je suis
bref la France résiste à la raison à
libéralisé nos barrages hydroélectriques
si demain on réinvestit dans nos
barrages c'est la meilleure énergie
renouvelable on gagne 20% de production
électrique sur nos barrages je souhaite
que la France dise que définitivement
elle gardera le monopole d'État sur les
barrages hydroélectriques parce qu'on ne
soumet pas la concurrence des
infrastructures aussi stratégiques que
d'autres que vous proposez en fait pas
du tout nous avons bâti l'Europe durant
des décennies en ayant pas le marché
européen de l'énergie je souhaite
simplement que d'ailleurs si on veut
redevenir européen on cesse de laisser
l'Europe faire n'importe quoi
[Musique]